the story opens up in a dense forest
with a young boy named Mowgli running
away from something along with a pack of
wolves in a desperate bid to escape
Mowgli climbs a tree to seek safety from
above unfortunately his plan goes awry
when he steps on a fragile branch and
tumbles to the ground at this moment
Bagheera a wise Panther who is cared
from ugly since he was a baby arrives
there to check on him he scolds Mowgli
for his recklessness stating that in a
real hunt he would have been captured or
worse he also emphasizes the importance
of staying close to the wolf pack for
safety in the next scene Bagheera
accompanies Mowgli to the wolf pack
where he has been raised by his wolf
parents Aquila and raksha despite his
strong connection with the wall of
smugly struggles to keep up with their
growth and learning Pace maybe it's
because he's not a wolf as the days pass
by the rainy season comes to an end and
the forest rivers begin to dry up this
exposes a special rock known as peace
Rock which signals that the water
sources are nearly exhausted during this
period animals are not allowed to hunt
near the Riverbanks so that all the
species can hydrate themselves
peacefully when Mowgli learns of this
she becomes excited and decides to head
to the riverbank raksha tries to stop
him saying it is too dangerous but he
just won't listen later while attempting
to collect water like a human Mowgli
inadvertently frightens the other
animals suddenly sheer Khan a menacing
tiger arrives at the scene driven by his
thirst for water despite the multitude
of animals present there shircon detects
the scent of a human and soon notices
Mowgli hiding behind a rock he then
starts approaching our boy but the
Wolves prepare to defend Mowgli at any
cost seeing this Shir Khan declares a
truce to respect the water shortage and
Promises to return once the river
returns threatening anyone who stands in
his way after enduring more weeks of
drought the forest finally sees rain
prompting the wolf pack to make a
difficult decision Aquila the wolf pack
leader chooses to send Mowgli to live
with his humans for his safety despite
raksha's initial resistance Bagheera
volunteers to accompany Mowgli on his
journey the rest of the pack also
understands that he can only be safe
from sheer Khan if he lives with humans
along the way Bagheera and Mowgli
encounter a herd of elephants and show
them great respect Mowgli believes that
they are the ones who created the forest
as they leave the jungle behind they
enter a vast dry grassland filled with
lots of Buffalo just then bhagira senses
danger and instructs Mowgli to lie low
his intuition turns out to be true as
Shir Khan emerges from The Tall Grass
attempting to attack Mowgli bhagira
swiftly intervenes engaging in a fierce
battle with the tiger however despite
his bravery he can't hold off Shir Khan
for long and is eventually defeated the
Ferocious Bengal tiger then turns his
attention to Mowgli and almost catches
him but at the same time some Buffalo
causes Stampede allowing the boy to
escape witnessing his prey slipping away
Shere Khan returns to the wolf pack and
approaches Akila questioning why they
haven't surrendered Mowgli in reply
Aquila explains that they've allowed
Mowgli to live with the humans to avoid
unnecessary conflict hearing this Shir
Khan becomes in raged and attacks Aquila
the Pax leader is then swiftly grabbed
by the neck and thrown from a cliff
leading to his death after dealing with
Aquila Shir Khan threatens the rest of
the wolf pack declaring that the jungle
is now his territory and he won't leave
until they return Mowgli to him
meanwhile Mowgli far away from this
chaos is riding on the back of a buffalo
says Mobley he is completely unaware
that his father is dead
it's not funny suddenly he notices a
landslide coming his way and jumps into
a river somehow he manages to cling to a
log and floats for quite a distance
until he reaches a safer area Mowgli
then starts searching for Bagheera but
comes across a gigantic snake's shed
skin instead hungry and tired he notices
some fruit hanging from a tree branch
using a piece of Vine he tries to reach
the fruit but he's surprised by a
raccoon that distracts him allowing
their group to steal the food realizing
he's been robbed Mowgli chases the
thieves up a tree ready to pop a cap in
that raccoon ass only to get surrounded
by a massive python named ka ka claims
to know Bagheera and slowly begins to
hypnotize Mowgli with its eyes at this
moment Mowgli remembers his past when
his father brought him into a cave to
protect him from sheer Khan he tried
scaring the tiger away with fire but was
eventually caught and killed luckily
Bagheera came to mowgli's rescue and
took him to the wolf pack back to the
present just as Kaw is about to devour
Mowgli a bear appears and intervenes
knocking the snake away during the
process Mowgli falls from a dangerous
height and gets knocked out the next
morning he wakes up in the cave of Baloo
the Bear the same one who saved him
Baloo asks Mowgli if he can climb and
when the latter replies with a yes he
asks for his help in obtaining honey
from a high mountain which is guarded by
countless bees reluctantly Mowgli agrees
to help Baloo who explains that he needs
the honey to survive the impending
winter Mowgli goes around the mountain
ties a vine to a tree and lowers himself
down to retrieve the honeycomb he
endures bee stings but manages to get
enough honey for Baloo afterward mugley
complains about the bee stings but
mentions that he must continue his
journey to the human Village before
sheer Khan catches up with him hearing
this Baloo realizes that he's being
pursued by a predator and decides to
guide Mowgli Through the Jungle to reach
the village while on their way Baloo
claims to know Bagheera and assures
Mowgli that he doesn't have to choose
between being human or wolf he also
offers him to be his friend and live a
Carefree life convinced by Baloo's words
Mowgli decides to stay in the jungle
helping him collect more honey and
improving his skills in the process they
spend their days crafting tools and
perfecting their techniques for getting
that honey one day while they're
swimming in the river Mowgli sends his
movement in the bushes and alerts below
out of nowhere Bagheera emerges from the
woods and scolds Mowgli before asking
him to continue their Journey to the
humans however Baloo persuades him to
wait until dawn so that they can spend
some more time together in the middle of
the night Mowgli hears the sound of
elephants and goes to investigate he
discovers a baby elephant trapped in a
crater and decides to help Mowgli
quickly gathers some Vines and ties them
to the young elephant while the adult
elephants help pull the calf to safety
this act earns Mowgli the Friendship of
these giant creatures leaving Bagheera
and Baloo in awe of his resourcefulness
despite this Bagheera remains steadfast
in his belief that Mowgli should be
taken to the human Village especially
since cheer Khan is relentlessly
pursuing him Baloo on the other hand
thinks that Aquila the wolf pack leader
can protect Mowgli in response Bagheera
reveals that Aquila has has already been
eliminated by sheer Khan this shocks the
giant bear and he finally understands
the gravity of the situation so with a
heavy heart Baloo himself approaches the
boy and advises him to go to the human
Village for his safety Mowgli expresses
his desire to stay but sadly the latter
pretends that he doesn't care about him
and only used him to get the honey this
hurtful lie prompts him ugly to leave
Baloo's territory with tears in his eyes
he then sits on a tree branch pondering
on what he should do next while on the
tree Mowgli is approached by monkeys who
grab him and playfully toss him along
the branches hearing his cries Bagheera
and Baloo chase after the monkeys and
eventually reach the base of an
extremely steep Mountain Mowgli is then
brought to a deserted Temple filled with
fruit and human artifacts as he explores
a gigantic orangutan hand emerges from
the Shadows revealing itself to belong
to King Louie it's me a monkey Louie
seems to know everything about Mowgli
and claims that he can protect him from
sheer Khan and other dangers in the
jungle but in return He demands that
mowglish show him how to control the red
flower which humans possess he is
actually talking about fire frightened
Mowgli denies having knowledge of the
flower and expresses his desire to leave
however King Louie is convinced that
Mowgli is hiding something so he starts
getting aggressive right then Baloo
arrives at the temple to distract King
Louis while Bagheera helps Mowgli sneak
out of the place as they are about to
escape one of the monkeys spots them and
alerts King Louis ensuing a deadly Chase
despite the overwhelming number of
monkeys Balu and Bagheera order Mowgli
to run ahead while they fend off the
monkeys however King Louie is determined
to capture the boy so he blocks his
Escape now with no way out Mowgli pleads
to be let go promising that he will
return to the wolf pack and seek akila's
protection at this moment King Louis
reveals that Aquila has been killed by
Shere Khan the Revelation shocks our boy
so much that he spirals out of control
he angrily climbs the Temple's steps
prompting King Louis to chase him Mowgli
then deliberately enters a fragile
section of the temple and when the
Colossal orangutan come comes after him
the pillar collapses witnessing the
destruction Bagheera and Baloo rush to
help Mowgli only to find him safe at the
top of a tree however the news of
aquila's death has made him change his
mind he is now determined to reach the
human Village when he finally reaches
the place smugly tries to approach the
central bonfire to get the red flower
AKA fire but is frightened by its size
so instead he grabs one of the Torches
and runs back to the Jungle while Baloo
and Bagheera search for him during his
journey Mowgli accidentally starts a
forest fire by knocking over some Embers
from the torch this movie is set in
California unaware of what he's done he
continues until he reaches a gathering
of animals by the river there Mowgli
challenges Shir Khan to a fight but the
tiger taunts him saying he is corrupting
the forest with the red flower to prove
shircon wrong Mobley tosses the torch
into the water and assures everyone that
he is one of them and not a human with
the torch now gone shircon mocks Mowgli
and prepares to attack but to his dismay
other animals step in to defend our boy
even though Shir Khan is outnumbered
he's fearless and takes on the pack of
wolves Baloo joins the fight but is
easily defeated by the Bengal tiger the
Wolves then engage in the battle to stop
Shir Khan while Bagheera advises Mowgli
to fight like a human using the terrain
to his advantage in the midst of the
chaos Mowgli flees towards the forest
and Shere Khan pursues him Bagheera also
follows them closely behind soon bhagira
catches up to Shir Khan and a fierce
fight ensues between the two big cats
despite delivering blows Bagheera is
overpowered and the Wolves intervene to
save him meanwhile Mowgli reaches a
burning part of the forest and recalling
bagheera's teachings he uses dead
branches to create a weapon he then sets
up a makeshift swing and cleans a tree
after a while Shere Khan arrives at the
scene Mowgli tries to make him fall by
luring him onto the weak branches but
the tiger climbs down to safer ones
frustrated Mowgli climbs higher ties the
vine to a branch and creates a swing at
this moment Shir Khan attempts to play
Mind Games explaining how he killed
Aquila this momentarily distracts Mowgli
and using this opportunity shircon
pounces on him luckily Mowgli snaps out
of his thoughts and uses the swing to
escape as Shere Khan is now on a weaker
Branch it snaps and breaks sending the
tiger plummeting Into the Fire to his
death on the other hand the injured
animals are worried from Mowgli they
believe that the Tiger has already
killed him but to their surprise Mowgli
arrives there with the herd of elephants
that he had helped previously he then
leads them to the riverbank and guides
them to break down the dead trees to
build a dam in the river the plan works
and after the water is diverted towards
the forest the fire is put out in no
time Mowgli has now taken revenge for
his father's death and has also become a
hero among the animals in the last scene
with her family reunited raksha declares
herself as the new leader of the Wolves
ensuring their safety the movie then
ends with Mowgli running along the
forest playing with the wolves and a
bulu who has started Living near him
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching